>> CHANEZON: Okay. Thank you. Hello, everybody.
Thanks for coming to Google I/O today. We
have a very social session this afternoon.
I hope we'll keep you entertained. I know
just after lunch like this, usually, it's
pretty hard, but we have lots of stuff to
show. So today, we have--the session is about
Friend Connect in the Real World, which is
real big sites who have implemented Friend
Connect and use it in the real world. And
we're going to go under the hood and show
you what the programming model is for making
your site social. So, with us today, we have
all the team from TIME.com: Shivani York,
Henry Chan, and Srivaths Lakshmi, Paul Berry
from Huffington Post and Khris Loux from JS-Kit.
So, it will be a very social session. A quick
reminder about the history of Friend Connect,
Friend Connect started in May 2008. There
was a preview where we showed the technology
and some sites were whitelisted to be able
to use it. And at that time, that preview
release was really for what we call "long
tail site," like small sites who don't have
much technical capabilities. And the goal
of Friend Connect was to enable them to become
social with just pasting a few bits of JavaScript
code. So you would register your site, put
your name, your URL, we would give you two
bits of script tags to paste into your page,
and, boom, with one script tag you would have
a member gadget or you could join the site.
I'm sure you have seen that in other sessions
or you have seen that all around the Web because
there are many, many websites who have adopted
that. And then, by pasting another bit of
JavaScript, you could add any OpenSocial application
there. And Google was providing a few of these
apps like commenting app, rating, and things
like that. So that was Friend Connect what
I like to call Vanilla, like very simple integration.
You have these rectangles into which social
part is unclosed, but then the rest of your
site is kind of untouched. In December 2008--so
May was like one year ago, we're kind of celebrating
the first birthday of Friend Connect. In December,
it was available to all sites and since then,
there are--a lot of sites have implemented
Friend Connect, but mainly, like, blogs and
community sites. In February, to make it even
easier, we shipped something called the Social
Bar where it was just a little bit of JavaScript.
You have this bar that appears at the top
of your site and then you can login to Friend
Connect there and you can have the commenting
gadget and things like that. So it's for even
easier integration. But where it gets really
more interesting is in March, which is two
to three months ago, we introduced two new
APIs for friend connect: the JavaScript API
and the REST API. And these ones allow you
to do deep social integration, integration
of social features in your website but really
integrating them completely with your website
the way you see fit. And we'll see with their
TIME.com or Huffington Post or JS-Kit, how
they did that kind of integration. So you
can do the integration on the client's side
using a JavaScript API or you can do it on
the server side using a REST API and you can
even do both. We'll see in the Time example
where we're using both APIs. And this API
is a good fit for teams with--for sites who
have a technical team and who have people
who can program and who really want to customize
the social experience of the users. Yes. So
we get by with a little help from my friends
in here. I'm going to call my friend Shivani
York from TIME.com, and she is going to explain
what we've been building together.
>> YORK: Okay. So I'm just going to give a
little bit of history of TIME.com. Thanks.
So the concept that we had is TIME.com Social
Lists. Just a little bit of history of what
TIME.com is. We're a 24-hour global news type.
We have over 150 journalists. We do in-depth
reporting. We, as for Omniture as of April,
we have about 142 million page views and 17
million unique visitors, and we're growing.
So, and this is our traffic as of April. As
I mentioned, we're growing. Our page was increased
by 195 percent year over year. We do have
users very engaged in our site. What we're
looking for is a way to give people fun things
to do around our lists. And I'm going to explain
that in a second. So what we have is Daily
Specials. So what are Daily Specials are?
These are like top 10, top 25 type of list.
We do them on a daily basis. We do them in
a monthly basis. They're just sort of like
a fun perspective on events that are current
events. So, recently, we did--when gas went
up to $4, I'm sure it was $5 here, 10 things
that you like about $4 gas. Then, recently,
we did Top 10 iPhone Applications for new
Oms, and one of our new Om editors did that.
So, and the topics ranged from both news,
heavy news type of content, so we had Pope
visiting the Middle East, top 10 things to,
like, fun things like the Top 10 Disastrous
Letterman Interviews. So they can be very
personal and fun in nature. So what we were
looking for is a way to make them more interactive,
a way to make them more social without having
a whole layer of application built-in. And
just to put that into perspective, our specials--and
specials include things like Top 100--Time
does like Top 100 list quarterly as well.
So those include those as well. And just in
the last six months, they've generated us
about 160--176 million pages. So they're big
business for us. And by nature, they're sort
of built in this quick list format where you
can--there is a photo on top, there is a video
on top, and you can quick gallery, you can
page through. So by--they lend themselves
very well to being engaged. So this is the
challenge that we've put in front of Patrick
and our front-end and back-end team is how
do we make these daily top 10 lists more engaging,
more social and more fun? So, I'm going to
show you a couple of our lists. So this is
one of our lists: Top 10 Movie Catchphrases
that we just did a couple of days ago. So
when you think of Terminator, what's the top
phrase that comes through your mind? Exactly,
I'll be back. You know, so there are lists
that are very personal to you, some of them.
The next one is--well, this is Gone With the
Wind, which I'm not really familiar with,
but there is Jerry Maguire. What's the Jerry
Maguire big phrase? "Show me the money." Great.
So what we did, we took an example. So this
example is going to be live. Actually, we're
going to be implementing on TIME.com probably
in the next couple of weeks as we workout
Kings. As Patrick mentioned, these are all
new APIs. So we're just sort of putting the
final touches on it. So, all this that you're
going to see is in demo mode. So, with all
of our daily lists, we have this full list
page, which hasn't been styled in anyway.
It's like a plain list page. These are the
five--these are the top 10 movie phrases.
For each page, you can go into it and see
what the phrase is. And then the same thing
for--because this is the example that we're
going to use--Top 10 Musical Politicians,
and I'm sure Bill Clinton is the one that
everybody is thinking about as I'm saying
this. And Bill Clinton is actually on the
list and he is number four on our list. So
imagine that list. So when you come to this
page, once we implement the Google Friend
Connect and the OpenSocial and the cloud computing
stuff, this is the page you're going to come
to. You're going to see the full Time list
on the left, so for every top 10 list, you're
going to see how our editors have ranked that
list, and you can click in to see why Colin
Powell made that list and see a little snippet
along with it and a video. So this is Colin
Powell doing the dance. And then when you
come back to it--so imagine at the end of
each list page, there is going to be a link
that's going to say, you know, click here
to re-rank and personalize this list and make
your own, or some, you know, better language
that we're going to come up with. So you're
going to come to this page, you're going to
be able to drag and drop it. Actually, no.
I think Bill Clinton is number one in here.
So Bill Clinton, Colin Powell, Sarah Palin,
Condoleezza Rice, and then you can save and
share that list. Again, one of the things
that we were looking at TIME.com, we're sort
of very platform agnostic, so we wanted to
make sure that we were able to leverage social
networks in communities that already existed
out there in the form of Google, Yahoo!, AOL,
OpenID, and then we're going to be implementing
Facebook soon. And while I'm saying that,
my friend developers give me a dirty look
because we do have Facebook implemented. It's
just not in the demo. So I'm going to sign
in with Google because it's a Google conference.
So, once I re-ranked the list in the order
that I like it, I can sign-in with one of
the social networks. And then, what I get
is, I get a list on the right that's my own
view of that list. So these are the four people
that I think should be in the Top 10 Most
Musical Politicians. And then what you also
get on the right is, you get like a user ranking
histogram which shows you how other people
have ranked each of those people--each of
the people on the list, how they've been ranked
by other users. You can get that link and
share it with friends then. So, I'm going
to open it, copy it, open another browser.
So, each of the URLs is unique. So each person,
we are allowing them, or each unique ID is
allowed to create one re-ranked list of Time
and then you can then share that in that URL
list and it's unique to you. And you can share
that with your friends, you can put it on
your Twitter, you can put on your Facebook,
and it's going to work any second. Is that
it? Sorry, guys, technical difficulties. Yup.
Okay. So, what you end up getting is, once
I share my list with Henry, if Henry comes
to this page, he'll get my Shivani York's
ranked list of Top 10 Musical Politicians,
and then you'll also get the Time list right
next to it, and then you can create your own.
And again, you can also, you know, share it
on Twitter and Facebook and stuff. So that's
essentially the concept and then I'll hand
it over to Henry and Srivaths to go into the
code.
>> CHANEZON: Okay.
>> SHIVANI: Should you talk about that?
>> CHANEZON: Yeah, and you show a little bit...
Yeah. So thanks, Shivani. Now, you've seen
the concept. Now we'll talk a little bit more
about that OpenSocial and cloud stuff and
go a little bit more in the details about
how this app was built. So TIME.com is served
static HTML pages. They're using Vignette
as the content management system. And thankfully
for us they were already using the jQuery,
a JavaScript Library, which have tested a
lot, build that application. So, basically,
what we wanted to do there was to have unique
URLs for users, having them the capability
to login using their credentials and an existing
social network and start customizing their
site and getting unique URLs that are personalized
to them. And the way we build that is with
a kind of new architect--a new type of architecture
that I think will happen more and more as
the Web or as Web pages become more distributed
in the next few years. There's a big trend
of--when you look at a website today and if
you're looking Firebug you'll see that, there's
a bunch of resources coming from many different
places, and actually the content coming from
the host that you have in your browser is
very often very little, and that movement
is just amplifying. And this is a very good
example of that. So here, the way we build
that is that we used Google Friend Connect
and Facebook Connect as well, the JavaScript
API. So, we use the Google Friend Connect
JavaScript API to let the user login using
their credentials on any social networks that's
part of Friend Connect. So, today there's
Yahoo!, Google, any OpenID provider or AOL.
There's a new one called Netlog in your Web
that implemented it, that was added to Friend
Connect, I think, only last week. So, 13 million
users just in one shot, and there are more
and more joining. So with that, you can login
using your credentials on an existing social
network. Then using the JavaScript API, we
have access to a UID for you and your display
name, and that's all that we're using in that
application. You also have access to thumbnail
URLs and things about your profile. That's
all we needed there. Facebook Connect provides
some similar functionality, although Henry
will tell you it's not as easy to use.
>> CHAN: But it works in my site. It's not
in live.
>> CHANEZON: And then--so that's for the social
part of it. So you don't have--Time didn't
have anything to modify. They don't have any
back-end, they didn't have anything to do,
just used these JavaScript APIs. Then, to
make the site--to store these lists and get
them and get the stats using the stats images,
for that, we used an App Engine application,
written in Python using, a Python App Engine
and we're using JSONP to get and set the data.
So JSONP is a way to make some calls to an
application that's hosting on a different
domain. Essentially, you're just getting your
URL that returns a script that's evaluated.
And in the URL, you pass a callback function
that will be called back with the data when
the callback comes. We'll show you a little
bit more what this looks like. When you are
doing a JSONP call, usually, it's not secure.
So the way we solve security is thanks to
these social APIs in Friend Connect. When
you are logging to Friend Connect, you have
a JavaScript function that you define that
is called back with a security token. And
that security token means Friend Connect--Google
tells you that Patrick logged in with his
Yahoo! account in Friend Connect. And that
security token, we pass it to the JSONP call
to the App Engine back-end. We'll show you
the Python code to do that a little bit later.
And on the server side, we use the Friend
Connect REST API to make the call on Patrick
with that security token to say, “Is this
really Patrick?” And then, that security
token comes from Friend Connect, so if I'm
really logged in and I have installed or invented
that token, then it's verified that I'm me
and that I can save in my name that list,
so that's how it works, which means that the
HTML page that you saw there, it's just cached
by your CDN and it's cached by your browser
and all the data is coming dynamically using
JavaScript to this page. And so, each user
can have URLs like ?userid=blah, listid=foo,
and then network=facebookconnect. And these
URLs would just serve you personalized list
for these users, that they can share with
their friends on social networks. So now,
Henry Chan from TIME is going to present to
you the code itself, the front-end code for
that app.
>> CHAN: Well, hello. Can I use--I'll just
sign out. Can I just sign out all the way
to the beginning?
>> CHANEZON: Oh, we're...
>> CHAN: All the way in the beginning.
>> CHANEZON: Okay.
>> CHAN: So, you just go--yeah, create a list.
All right. So, basically, since Vignette doesn't
have like back-end, so we can't really show
the dynamic data. What I did here was, like,
on every page load, we use Friend Connect
to, like, grab data from...
>> CHANEZON: Yeah, yeah, go on.
>> CHAN: Grab data from the Google Friend
Connect to pop--to basically, like, if I forgot
what state this application is at, you go
to the Firebug. You scroll down--you scroll
up a little. Within these slides, these are
the things I'm passing, basically a list ID.
Username is undefined because we're not logged
in. And then we go all the way down where
you see the security token that Patrick was
talking about. So, right now, the state is
that I'm logged out and I'm not looking at
the list. So, basically, I'm generating a
page using the HTML to look like--might as
well look--well, sort of functionalities,
so you sort rate. You just start dragging
stuff off now?
>> CHANEZON: Yeah.
>> CHAN: Basically, we're saving it in an
array and we go--you scroll all the way down.
We click the "save and share," thus, it generates
a JSONP call to try to send to, like, put
list which is basically saving it and also
sending in a security token. But since you're
not--since you're not logged in, it won't
allow you to save until you're logged in.
So just login to Yahoo!.
>> CHANEZON: Sure.
>> CHAN: So, basically, as soon as Patrick
sign on, Chanezon page reload and cookies
and all these other settings has already been
updated, so it changed the user view to a
"I'm logged in and I'm looking at my own list,"
because you just created your own list so
it goes through back to it. With this dashboard,
we have all these links on the social list,
which is also dynamically generated. And these
are like--so the way we are, like, kind of
storing these data is by using just basic
storing, like, a short survey of like the
list and the number that got a range on it.
So, with this way, we don't really have to,
like, do any back-end and allow you to check
to make sure, like, a user is, like, passing
the correct list title and all that. So you
scroll down. You go to the "net."
>> CHANEZON: Oh, yeah.
>> CHAN: Net. Go to "HTML." All right. So
you scroll down to get list of URL IDs, so
that is the JSONP call. So, you click "response."
Basically, it brings us back the name which
will pop later on the left side and also the
data to the way that list is ordered. Okay.
What else I want to show?
>> CHANEZON: Maybe we could show the HTML.
>> CHAN: All right. So, essentially, that's
the part two initialized Friend Connect to
load. And as soon as we load the API, it goes
to my--which is top 10 model for that JS.
>> CHANEZON: Yeah. So for those of you who
have used any of the Google AJAX APIs, we
use a common loader. So that's this google.com/jsapi.
And once you've loaded that, you can say Google
load and then some API, like in this case,
Friend Connect 0.8. Maybe the JavaScript now.
>> CHAN: Yeah. So you want to go to the JS.
>> CHANEZON: Sorry? Oh, it's on--so, oh, the
API for Friend Connect. So, you can find the
API description at code.google.com/friendconnect,
but one of the nice thing about Friend Connect
is that the JavaScript API is, in fact, the
OpenSocial API. So there are a few calls that
are specific to Friend Connect, like request
to sign in, things like that, or logout which
are really specific to adding OpenSocial to
your own page instead of being in a gadget,
inside of a container. But the rest of it
is just Vanilla OpenSocial API. And we can
show you some of the code here. It's like
Vanilla. Actually, she has the JavaScript
code. Yeah. Sorry? It's code.google.com/friendconnect.
So you'll find the overall documentation there.
And in the Friend Connect specific documentation,
there's only, I think, there's five or six
functions that are specific to Friend Connect.
All the rest is the OpenSocial API, and you
see it here. Excuse me? Thanks, Missy. You're
right. So the URL is code.google.com/apis/friendconnect.
And so here, we're looking at the--let's make
it a little bit bigger. We're looking at the
JavaScript source code of that app where really
the action happens. So, in it...
>> CHAN: Because if you want to...
>> CHANEZON: Yeah.
>> CHAN: So we should really go here.
>> CHANEZON: Yeah. So in there, we're using
a lot of jQuery, like all the drag and drop
is done using jQuery drag and drop. Hopefully,
Time was using it already. So it was really
a breeze to have it.
>> CHAN: Yeah. So, basically, this portion
of the code, like, based on, like, the cookie
and the URL, it will tell what state you're
on and based on what state you're on. Like,
this function lobe basically builds the page
and the view and also does any associated
behavior associated to that view.
>> CHANEZON: Yeah. I think we're good for
the JavaScript. You can take a look at the
JavaScript at that URL. All these URLs will
be in my delicious links after this presentation,
and they're in the slides. So the slides will
be published on the Google I/O Conference,
but I'm going to push them to my blog tonight.
So, if you look for, like, Chanezon, that's
the first thing you will find and you'll find
them there, or look at my Twitter or my FriendFeed.
It's all over the place. One last thing we
wanted to show you. Thanks very much, Henry.
We're kind of a little bit late. So Srivaths
is going to tell us a little bit more about
the back-end part of this.
>> LAKSHMI: Hello, everybody. My name is Srivaths,
I'm the technical lead of TIME.com. Currently,
we are using Vignette content management system.
There is no real database for this Friend
Connect to be supported. So what we did is
we started using App Engine from Google. I'm
sure many of you have heard about it and to
the [INDISTINCT] about App Engine. And with
the App Engine, we are able to send a secure
token and the list ID from our packages, which
we call as full list. And with that, we are
able to authenticate and get it back using
just a simple call from the JavaScript. Let
me show you the App Engine all here. In the
data view or if you see here, the first one
is the ID or the name, what you are using.
And second one is the date when the user put
on the task, whether he either turns this
thing on or created a new account, a new list.
The third one is the list ID and the fourth
one is the network. Sorry. The fourth one
is the network, which is currently FC.
>> CHANEZON: So FC is for Friend Connect.
>> LAKSHMI: Yeah. The network is Friend Connect
and the product is mostly Google all here.
If you have logged in by a Yahoo! or AOL,
those URLs will be shown in order.
>> CHANEZON: Oh, yeah, the Python is in there.
>> LAKSHMI: All right. It's really very easy
to use this App Engine, as they mentioned
in the early morning in the [INDISTINCT] presentation.
All you do is write Java or Python code and
it's very easy to deploy in the App Engine.
And I believe it's free for now. So it's good
to give it a try.
>> CHANEZON: It's free for up to 5 million
page use.
>> LAKSHMI: Okay. That's good. If you're going
to get more than 5 million page uses, you
are going to get enough revenues in that.
Someday you'll be able to pay for that. And
this is the Python Code. It's basically, like,
less than 200 hundred lines of code. And the
whole concept of this full list and Friend
Connect was done in less than three weeks.
So you can imagine how fast this can be integrated
with Google Friend Connect. And few of the
main things here is, like, if you see the
user ID, list IDs, swaps, token, callback,
these are all the items which are used. And
as Henry mentioned in its core, the swaps
will be showing, okay, the zero list ID has
been switched to nine, nine list ID have been
switched to one, something like that. Everything
is done in JSONP call and the callback returns
you with the necessary results for here. Well,
if you guys have any questions, we are available
in the Sandbox until 6 p.m. today. And we
can walk you through and give some tries on
trying to create some new list and see how
it works. Thank you very much.
>> CHANEZON: Thanks. Okay, so that was the
TIME.com application. As Shivani said, they're
working to finalize this and push it in production
very soon. And on my side, the part of the
code that makes it at least social, like the
jQuery plug-in plus the App Engine back-end,
I'm probably going to push that as an open
source project so that anybody can make their
really social. And it chooses Friend Connect
and Facebook Connect. So now, we have Paul
Berry from HuffingtonPost, who's going to
show us what these guys have built there.
>> BERRY: Hi, guys. Well, that's loud. Okay.
I'm just going to run through a bunch of things
and we can kind of go fast and show you guys
a quick background of HuffingPost.com. It's
about three years old, three and a half years.
We're doing about 22-23 million UVs a month
according to Google Analytics. We're at 250
million page views a month. And what I'm going
to show you is totally live on the site right
now, and has been doing great. We've just
really stepped--we've been cramming like mad
to have things ready for hearings. So there's,
you know, there's things that are kind of
often, there's things we can't wait to build,
but we're really excited as an organization
about Friend Connect and Social in general.
And the features we've done have been taken
off wildly and we're really excited about
them. We had on one particular--well, let
me back out a moment to just say that we're
very concerned about making sure that you
can connect from any social network into Huffington
Post and then have a very social experience
from there. So part of, like, built-in to
the login screens--let me just ran back here--is
Friend Connect. And, basically for us, once
you do sign in through Friend Connect or Facebook,
you become a HuffPost user. And you go through
a process that I won't go through right now,
but basically, you choose your username based
on your existing Gmail or Facebook username.
It does a check to see if is this duplicated
or, you know, is there a Paul Berry in the
system already? And then, check maybe you
are the Paul Berry and you know your HuffPost
password and you want to be able to sign in
with Facebook and use social features. Or,
you know, is this a new user name that you
have to choose because someone already has
yours? And then, we pull on profile photos
and we scan for any existing friends from
that social network in ours already. So we
have--just one thing to show is, like, this
is a random profile page that I picked just
quickly before. But there's about 450,000
HuffPost users who have about 300,000 relationships
between each other. So the Facebook Connect
piece and the Friend Connect piece have been
really juicing that and adding to it. But
it's important for us as we build these things
that we're not leaving our original user base
behind and that we're using these social backbones.
So--and then, just randomly there's--you can
see how much people create these connections
between each other. The fun thing--and I think
we can kind of get right into it--is basically
the social slideshow is what we're calling
it. And it combines a slideshow that is kind
of a monster page view generator with voting
and social and creating your own lists. So,
if--so for example, this swimsuit--I mean,
yes, it's babes, so this going to do well
in traffic, but it's been doing crazy well.
There were, you know, I don't know this morning
when I checked on it, there have been 50,000
votes in the last couple hours. So people
are going through and they're doing this vote
and they're saying, "Yeah, this Bettie Page
swimsuit is pretty hot." But then they're
going into this next section and they are
choosing their own top five. So, they can
say, all right, I'm going to put Phoebe at
two and Denny Moore here, Bridgette Bardos
is pretty hot, okay, Welch, and then you now
have this, and I won't go into the Facebook
stuff, but, you know, publish this to your
stream there and that's adding a lot of viral
component. With Friend Connect, it's a little
bit different and it sends you in through
an invite process that I will not sign in
as you, sorry. And I won't be remembered here.
How's that? Unfortunately, like these are
some things to sort out, is that this pop-up
thing is kind of annoying extra step that
people have trouble with. But the idea is
that then off to your left, you have all the
users, all your Gmail contacts so it's really
easy to grab a bunch of them, and then add
someone by email and send them. And then,
basically, what they get sent to is a lot
like--I think we were just having an issue
with this. So it's not exactly how it will
look to them, but very similar to--oh, and
this worth taking a quick moment on. We're
going to work out because thousands of users
have rated this slide, showing more people
and having sort of a Jackson or action to
flip through them. But, you know, we're making
it possible for people to see who rated--like
Sean Lynn rated this slide at 10 out of [INDISTINCT]
or 10 out of 10 and etcetera, and so you kind
of see how they're reacting and voting on
a particular one. And then--this, yeah, this
is--so when you send it out to your friends
through Gmail, you come to a screen that's
similar like this, with a light box that pops
up. And there's things--its design is kind
of ugly with a lot of extra white space, and
so things to clean up there. But the most
important thing is that you're able to now
let, you know, this user put up her top five
and have everyone react to that. So, basically--and
then as you step through these things you
have a similar screen, but this has--we've
launched, I think, the editors have a really
nice fast tool to be able to launch these
and create different "I wouldn't wear, I would
wear," type of rankings to make it a game
and a voting thing. We've seen about 20 million
page views to these slideshows in the last
week alone. So, it's been really exciting
and there's definitely a lot more we have
to do. But our platform had just done sort
of back to the nerd level for us all, is our
platform is 70 percent Perl and 30 percent
PHP. And it gives us a flexibility that combined
with the APIs here is really, you know, what
we've developed here, we got really into it
and got crazy workaholic, but it's two or
three weeks of work that we've gone through
for this. So I think it is huge props to Google
and Friend Connect for also helping us through
it a little bit with advice. But it's pretty
awesome what publishers have, you know, as
a resource to them. So, I think that's--you
have a question, Clint?
>> CLINT: [INDISTINCT]
>> BERRY: Is there like a relationship map
for that was--that we look at. We are not
really looking at like, okay, how many friends
does this user have beyond the profile pages
which are public. So, we're looking at our
total numbers and how they're growing at that
level. But--and then, sort of if I want to
look at one particular user, their network
is sort of publicly visible. I don't think
I'm really getting your question, though.
All right, so okay.
>> CHANEZON: Okay. Thanks very much, Paul.
Okay. So, what you saw is essentially took
publishers using Google Friend Connect user
to create a brand new community on their site
or in the case of HuffingtonPost, just to
expand an existing community. Now, we have
Khris Loux. Khris? Oh, yeah. So, Khris Loux
from JS-Kit is going to give us another perspective
on Friend Connect. Thanks, Khris.
>> LOUX: You're welcome. Is this on? Thumbs
up, yeah. Okay. Good. Good. I'm on one of
these tabs or I think... Wait a second, maybe
she whacked it.
>> CHANEZON: Let me see.
>> LOUX: See if you can find it.
>> CHANEZON: Yeah, yeah. Exactly.
>> LOUX: In any case, my name is Khris Loux,
and I'm the CEO and co-founder of JS-Kit and
essentially a widget maker or widgeteer, and
we provide social networking components for
websites, commenting systems, ratings, polls,
a lot of the same type of technologies that
you saw up there. They're general purpose
tools. People come to our site, they copy
the code, paste it into their website and,
wallah, off they go. So the interesting thing
about Google Friend Connecting and what we're
doing here is it's really a transformation
from building an experience on your site to
distribution. All right. Engagement is answering
a poll question, pretty interesting occupy
someone's time, but the ability to take that
whole result and push it to a billion accounts
is really interesting and really worth while
and those are the type of technologies with
Facebook Connect, Google Friend Connect, Yahoo!
Updates, Microsoft Live, Twitter, etcetera,
etcetera. This is the next sort of wave. I
mean, I think we all have engagement down
to a science. It's now how do we get the content
that's on our site shattered and splintered
and sent out through the rest of the Internet.
I think I gave the same presentation three
weeks ago. So we can either just play it or
maybe I'll do it live. I don't know which
one. In any case, that's me but that's not
why I did that. There's slides or something
along those lines which I didn't give--I think
it's the slide as the last time, so I don't
think I should actually be allowed to use
them again this time. But the guys--the boys
and girls that were up here earlier essentially
told you to be how to get this stuff engaged,
and much of it, I just learned for the first
time today. It's a beautiful chase on or whatever
that was. What I want to describe is, why
you would implement Google Friend Connect
and why truly it is your friend and the community's
friend writ large? And it goes back--or I
should say the story begins a couple months
ago. When Facebook released their first publisher
side application and it was a commenting widget,
and most people didn't notice except for--if
you're a commenting company and you sort of
get, "Oh, man, we got a large competitor.
Now, what we do about it?" Well, one of the
ideas is that we would change business models
and maybe bake cookies or something like that,
and so, none of us can bake, so maybe we'll
stay in the commenting business. So, how do
we turn a brand new gigantic competitor into
a super huge opportunity? And that's really
what Facebook Connect and Google Friend Connect
allowed us to do. So, before I dive down into
this, I want to describe how clever and interesting
the Facebook model is and how you can leverage
it and how you need to be careful of it all
at the same. I view Facebook as room, right?
They've consolidated the social networking
space for this particular cycle. How long
it last, who knows, but the hard argue that
they haven't wanted for now, I mean, their
growth chart is like the shuttle taking off.
They have, you know, multiple countries. They're
winning in Europe, in Asia, in the United
States. They're winning across demographics.
It's my grandmother, my mother, my kids, everyone's
on Facebook right now and so they've got room
and they've consolidated their power there.
What they then did very cleverly was to build
roads out of room, right? Facebook Connect,
it gets them off of their dot-com and then
this first application, comments, is a garrison.
It's a publisher side application that sits
off of facebook.com and it is now outside.
And so, there's logic that says, "Hey, the
walled garden is dead and it doesn't work."
Well, that's fine except for their strategy
is to expand the walled garden until it's
every dot-com, right? And it's beautiful and
I hope this stuff, it doesn't work because
there would be no room for us. No, no, no.
It's a good strategy. You need to ask the
question, especially the Google Conference,
right, are they evil and the answer is no.
They're being extremely rational, right? It's
a logical step to expand off of their domain,
leverage what they've got to expand to a wider
sphere. Okay. So what do we, what do we do
it all of this? If we view it externally,
we could kind of look at the social networking
stack that they've created in a similar way
to the elegant stack that Apple created with
the Apple music stack, right? And it may be
the Facebook's social networking stock will
be as brutally effective as Apple was against
the MP3 player industry. Can you name another
MP3 player company? Yeah, I can't either.
So, what that means is they're in a position
to dominate writ large and things like Yahoo!
Updates, Google Friend Connect, Twitter, etcetera,
or really counter balances to that and in
this time of transition, it's an opportunity
for us, the community, to take some of the
power back. Okay. So, what is--what are the
stakes in all of this? If you look at the
larger technology cycles, kind of IBM, Microsoft,
Google, question mark, who's next, you see
some things that happen. When IBM dominated
their stack, right, the hardware stack, the
application, they wind up controlling innovations
and revenues for 20 years, right? '70s and
'80s were just, it was IBM. And then, when
they, let's say, handed the crown to Microsoft,
whether it was taken or handed, you know,
that's for the historians to talk about, but
when the crown was passed to Microsoft, Microsoft
was our savior. Does anyone remember this?
This was like in that late '80s. I bought
some of their first stock. I was in college.
It was so exciting and they saved us from
the evil empire of IBM at the time, and that
was great. They were our new savior until
one thing, until I got locked at it, and then
it sort of sucked for another couple decades
as they ground out all of the innovations
and all of the revenue. I mean, by and large
they took the heartbeat out of the industry
and it left a bunch of us that were coding
on the sidelines, right, to get little crumbs
off of the side of this behemoth. And you
can see what happens is, they take--I'll just
make a point on this. The incumbent is a stifle
to innovation, right, their innovation adverse.
Why at the time should Microsoft innovate?
All I have to do is wait, right? WordPerfect
grows and it's beautiful and they can get
revenue, so they released Word, oh, a third
the prize and they completely cannibalized
that company and those sets of technologies,
and so they just wait on this thing. They
keep going and keep grinding it out and if
they get it wrong it doesn't matter. They
just throw that product out and try again
and try again, because the core revenue was
off the operating system. They didn't have
to win with word processing. And you see,
again, the cycle went and it was handed or
taken, or evolved to Google, right? When we
moved from the OS as a desktop application
to the Internet as the operating system--if
you'll allow that as an analogy--the same
types of processes happened again, right?
What did it cost or what does it cost Google
to release Google Spreadsheet or Google Docs,
right? Not too much. It's a great application,
works real well, but it has this perverse
effect of taking core revenue out of the prior
incumbent, right? Every license that didn't
get solved, there's a revenue right of Microsoft's
pile, and it doesn't hurt Google at all. And
so these are giant cycles that are happening
and this is why this evolution, this little
timeframe right now were the social graph
is not yet owned is important, and it's important
for us, is, you know, visitors, and publishers
and developers to kind of seize the day here.
We have a choice of either kind of going through
this, the cycle of, you know, anoint the king
and then crucify them and anoint another king
and then crucify them, or we can decide as
a community that we want self rule, right,
that we want to empower ourselves, that we
want to own the innovation work flows and
the resulting revenue flows from these technologies.
And there's some early warning signs here.
Take a look at Twitter or Facebook. Now, Facebook
had an opportunity to buy Twitter and, you
know, personally I think they, or at least,
they were in negotiations. I think they should've
done it, personal opinion, probably another
talk, but at the end of the day they didn't
have to buy them, right? What did they do?
They reworked Facebook to include that core
technology. They didn't need to innovate Twitter.
They just needed to copy it. And so, these
early signs are here. And so, there's an approach
that can be taken here that could be, again,
fearful, what do we do? Back off, integrate
Facebook, don't integrate Facebook, etcetera.
Or, we can take an absorption strategy, which
works very well against one player. And so
the advice that I would give this group as
I have with our own company is not to view,
you know, either Google Friend Connect or
Yahoo! or Microsoft or Facebook is either
evil or negative, or whatever. They are all
opportunities. So in our particular development
path, we implemented OpenID, we implemented
Facebook Connect, Google Friend connect, Twitter,
etcetera, etcetera. So, instead of having
a situation where we have 200 million users
from Facebook, we now have access to a billion
users and we now have leveled this playing
field. So we no longer make a decision when
someone uses our commenting service or our
rating service or our poll service, what social
network the visitors need to use. They should
just pick the one that they like, right? In
so doing, we divide out the strength, right?
We pass things out so that it's more of a
level playing field, and the benefit endorsed
to us, right? When someone leaves a comment
on one of our sites, it pushes to all of their
Twitter users, all of their Facebook users,
all of their Yahoo! YM buddies, etcetera,
etcetera, etcetera. That's power, right? Engagement
is on the site. The tools like Google Friend
Connect allow you to blast this content out
and get tens of thousands of users engaged.
And quite frankly, HuffPost guy with the little
photos, man, you start putting that--those
types of things out on Facebook and Twitter,
etcetera, you're going to drive traffic. I
was engaged. In fact, what was the link to
that site anyway? But this is the larger reason.
This is the larger issue of why you would
do these things? It is more work, right, to
integrate both Facebook and Google Friend
Connect, but it is gigantic in its ramifications.
It's an existential question. It's not really
a development question. It's a question of,
"If you want your products or your websites
to survive long-term, then you need to implement
and integrate both of these sets of technologies."
I think we're crushed for time. I have two
seconds. What do I say? Okay. That's it. A
wrap. All right. Thank you very much. I appreciate
it.
>> CHANEZON: Thank you. Yeah. So, I don't
have time for Q and A, but all of us will
just be outside. So just grab us for questioning
for there and I hope that this will give you
a good idea of how to implement Friend Connect
and why you should do it, and hood luck seizing
all these opportunities. Thanks.